hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in nikka Makeda
ethics book 10 Aristotle tells us a bit
more about what he's been covering
through the rest of the work that is the
life of virtuous activity or what we
often call the active life the life
oriented around virtue and as opposed to
the rest of the work where he's been
saying that this is the primary way that
human beings attain happiness he
actually tells us that the life of
virtuous activity is the second best
life it is not the best life when it
comes to attaining happiness there is a
higher life that that is the life of the
contemplative the theoretical life the
life of the philosopher which is
primarily engaging our intellect and
which develops our intellectual virtues
that's not a life that most people are
indeed living a hope it is perhaps a
possibility for our own time in a way
that was not for Aristotle due to
technology why is the life of virtuous
activity which is a great life by the
way for Aristotle don't get me wrong
he's not
if there's anything intrinsically wrong
with it as a matter of fact second best
is pretty pretty good why is it second
best though he gives us a number of
considerations some of which you may
find more compelling than others and we
should look at each of these in turn so
he says that the virtues that are
connected that are concerned with action
the moral virtues or is he saying it
there the practica ought to die right
involved a kind of lack of leisure a
lack of scolding a lack of being able to
do what we want with our own time or a
lack of rest and the two modes that he
talks about in relation to that for
examples are political and military so
you know we might think for ourselves
what else might fall under this life of
activism devoted to a worthy cause not
to some cause that somebody picked just
because they like holding up signs and
yelling at people but really working for
justice within the political realm could
be understood as a kind of political
life not only power but doing something
along those lines I think as well that
here taking occupations probably fit in
their education when it's done right
could certainly be a life of active
virtue that's not to say that many
educators are and the advertis as a
matter of fact that experience shows us
that not to be the case that you can
despite a lot of talk about that sort of
thing eating it among people doing
virtue ethics and we could go on and on
you know what what other professions
what other ways of living committed ways
of living might be involved with that
that's a good question to consider for
yourself what do they have in common
they aim at securing some other good now
Aristotle does still think that virtue
is something that we want to pursue for
its own sake it is a good in itself but
it is also a productive good and the
life of deploying virtue as well as
developing her to the life of actually
doing things it is going to be a life
that lacks leisure in part because we're
aiming at something beyond just that
that particular activity so it more
Aristotle says the goal is peace he
actually thinks that if you pursue in
war for its own sake there's something
fundamentally wrong with you he says
it's not only here but in the politics
in the case of the political life you're
aiming at the happiness of yourself and
hopefully also your your fellow citizens
I would say if you're involved in some
sort of organization there's going to be
some some good in the organization and
when organizations actually lose sight
of what goods are attempting to attain
and they become all about profit they
lose their cohesiveness they lose their
morale as we call it which comes from
the word morale they cease to be you
might say environments in which the
virtue is not only can be cultivated but
can be displayed and in which that can
can play role within the organization
all that said this is a very important
point there's a certain constraint in
this by necessity to the life of virtue
so if you accept that as a flaw with it
you're going to do that is making its
second best another issue activities of
moral virtue are as Aristotle says
purely human they are not animal right
but they're not divine either human
beings are located within a continuum
between the divine and the animal we're
somewhere in between and what places us
there is is several things too to which
I am on the board and one which I should
actually put up there and I made you so
so what one of them is it we have bodily
existence right we are not just
disembodied souls floating around we
exist here in these bodies these bodies
have needs requirements they have to be
me
tained you know the result sets of
things that go along with that and so
the activities of moral virtue are
involving that aspect of our existence
our passions and our desires you know
Aris level says the moral virtues not
only have to do with actions they have
to do with our emotions are popping
there's another word for passion and
desire our exes are what is that drives
us the other thing is that we are social
animals Aristotle says that a human
being who did not need other people
would either this is in the politics
would either be a god or a beast but not
a human being yeah there's something
intrinsically social to us and the
virtues are connected with that that's
not to say that you can't be social
while you're engaged in the life of
contemplation but it's less so another
point to this is that the life of
virtuous activity involves less
self-sufficiency than the life of
contemplation why well it requires a
greater amount of external goods we need
more things in order to be able to say
be generous or even to be able to be
courageous or temperate we probably need
some of the goods in part and we're
developing towards virtue as same reason
why we need scratch paper when we're
writing you know a novel or planning out
a video or something like that we make
mistakes that consume goods and so you
know we require a certain amount of
external wealth or goods we also require
friends as Aristotle has noted you know
in addition to that and that's something
that's why the life of virtuous activity
just by itself just being virtuous is
not actually to make
you happy it's virtuous activity number
one with enough wealth added so that you
can exercise the virtues the latest
thing that he says is particularly
interesting it takes us into a
theological dimension aerosol does not
have a particularly articulated
well-developed doctrine about about
religion or the gods but here is what he
says at this point so this is sort of a
rejection of the rather anthropomorphic
notion of the gods that you would find
say in Homer where the gods are are
fighting on the sides of the Greeks or
the Trojans or are getting involved in
love affairs with each other or are
sometimes getting stabbed by mortals
because other gods equip them to stab
them or you know we could go on and on
seeking revenge you know whether the
children are hurt so eros level says the
gods as we can see them enjoy supreme
Felicity and happiness but what sort of
actions going to be a tribute to them
just actions well when they actually
engage in just actions he says if it
will seem ridiculous to think of them as
making contracts restoring deposits in
the life they don't they don't make each
other loans or anything like that what
about brave actions and during tears and
running risks for the nobility of so
doing what's going to scare a guy gods
are the top of the food chain on to
logically speaking or liberal actions
generous actions but to whom will they
give besides says it would be absurd to
suppose they actually have a queen itch
or currency of some sort and the
Aristotle saying with all these human
anthropomorphic conceptions they don't
really work the gods are engaged in
contemplation primarily they're not
actually engaged in actions of moral
virtue so when the poets are saying
things about them is being morally
virtuous they're actually on base and we
may like to think that we should imitate
them but we're not imitating the reality
of the gallery
imitating some sort of poetic
imaginative image that helps us do the
right thing the way that we ought to so
we don't for example go and sleep with
our neighbors spouse the way that Aries
does with [ __ ] as's spouse Aphrodite
we don't engage in all sorts of terrible
revenge in as you know all the way these
sorts of things so again I wanted really
stress that the life of virtue is not a
bad life as a matter of fact it's better
than all the other wives except for one
life and that is the life of
contemplation and here are the reasons
why aerosol gives for that